it all right
all right fantastic uh so let me welcome
next emma brunskill
uh who's going to tell us about uh batch
reinforcement learning with that great
exploration so take it away by my please
thanks um it's great to be here um and i
think it's gonna be i'm really excited
for this morning um it's great to get to
go after tenu and um i think
me tangy and sergey and all of the
people this morning are very interested
in some related topics
um i wanna first say that this is based
on uh work with my great phd student
yalu
and as well as some wonderful colleagues
at msr and this work will be appearing
at nuretz
um and it's on archive so i think
uh i i want to first start and just sort
of say a little bit about the type of
problems that i find
really exciting and i think one of the
things that i find really interesting
about reinforcement learning is it can
help us think about
many different types of decision making
problems including health care things
like how can we use historical data
to understand whether or not putting
someone on a ventilator would maximize
their chance of survival
which is obviously very very um topical
right now
and then other questions i'm very
interested in education and ai for
education
and you know how would we do something
like adaptively teach algebra to
students
algebra is a problem that often is a
linchpin
in not allowing students to go forward
in terms of their career aspirations
and so there's a lot of interest in how
do we help people learn algebra
and so how would we sort of adaptively
have an ai agent to teach students
algebra
to maximize or increase the number of
students that pass that course
so these sorts of questions are all
ultimately decision making under
uncertainty
questions i think they're under
uncertainty because we don't have great
models of how people learn
or their physiology um and so we put
sort of our lack of understanding um and
treat these things as stochastic
emma before you go on i'll just store
interrupt drop your screen is quite
small
uh at least on my screen it's probably
fine for now
uh but if there's small diagrams we
might need to zoom in does that make a
difference if i make it larger
this is much better okay so i'll make it
larger on my side i didn't know that
that
i assumed it would just show the full
screen there we go um let me know if
that's still a problem later
so um sorry then i went back a little
bit
okay good so in um so i think this
question i mean
you know how do we quickly learn to make
good decisions under uncertainty and
reinforcement learning in general is not
only um a really
core question in intelligence but it's
also going to be fundamental for us to
be able to answer these sort of
questions from an ai
and a computational perspective and most
of the work that we do in my
lab can be sort of summarized by this
simple question of
how do we learn from limited samples to
robustly make good decisions
and one aspect of that is this sort of
learning from historical data
and i know you're going to hear this
motivation repeatedly
through the um through the morning but i
think it's really important and it's a
really exciting area
so if we look at something like
healthcare um because of
uh previous legislative changes at least
in america
there's now a huge incentive for
hospitals to use electronic medical
record systems
and one of the um things that was passed
when incentives were put in place for
that
was not only to collect that data but
the hospitals had to show how it was
being used
to improve on patient care and so if you
come into this from a reinforcement
learning perspective you immediately
think well how can we leverage that
historical data
in order to improve patient outcomes i
also have been doing some an informal
survey of a number of wonderful
colleagues some of which are um on
this call as well to ask people about
why they thought
reinforcement learning isn't in practice
as much as what we've seen for
supervised learning
and one of the question responses i got
repeatedly back
is that the ask for changing sort of
workflows
to an online rl case where we have
online systems
is a very big systems change for many
many organizations
but the idea we know to use batch rl um
to take historical data
figure out better policies that then can
be deployed if they're good
that's actually a much smaller sort of
systems lift
and so i think that being able to tackle
and provide good battery enforcement
learning algorithms
could be a really major step forward in
terms of allowing many industries and
organizations
to leverage sort of the ideas and power
of reinforcement learning
so just to be precise because i think
there's a lot of different
words we use to describe batch or
offline
off policy reinforcement learning um i
want to be clear that what i mean in
this case is the
the setting where we have a data set of
a certain number of trajectories
um i'm going to think today about cases
not the infinite horizon case but where
we have sort of
episodes um think of this as patients or
students and we're going to assume that
that data is collected by a behavior
policy
um and that behavior policy may or may
not be known so in a lot of the health
care settings i think about
the behavior policy of a physician is
not written down um so it's sort of
implicit
so we're going to assume aside from that
that we're in the standard batch rl
setting
um but we're not going to be able to do
any online exploration
and this sort of question really
requires us to do what if reasoning
um and so we're thinking about things
that we have this historical data
and we would like to be able to figure
out for example for you know a next
episode or a new patient
how to treat them given our historical
data and of course the challenges is
that we can't go back
and think about what would have happened
if we treated somebody in a different
way
just like right now you can't think
about how much better your life might be
if you were
you know drinking a coffee in a
starbucks right now
similarly we can't go back and rewind
and replay
um sort of different outcomes for
patients but the second thing that i
want to highlight
and this problem has been well known in
econometrics and statistics and bandits
for a long time this issue of sensory
data
but i think that you know in
reinforcement learning it gets even
harder um and the reason it gets even
harder is because we're thinking about
sequences of decisions
and so the combinatorics if we don't
exploit structure
get really bad really quickly and we're
just not going to be able to do
randomized control trials for every
possible sequence of different types of
um
treatments and so we're going to need to
do some form of generalization or have
some sort of policy class structure
in order to make progress so i'm going
to focus
uh today sort of first really spend some
time thinking about
trying to highlight what is the type of
goal i would like to achieve in this
area
and i'm excited to discuss this more
with people around 11 30.
so one goal that i've been very
interested in over the last few years is
you know how do we do something
equivalent to structural risk
minimization
so we have some old data in the in the
batch reinforcement learning setting
we would like to be able to do some sort
of model selection and policy selection
and be able to compare across different
types of model classes and policies
so that we could find a good policy to
deploy in the future
um and these sort of guarantees are well
known
for um the supervised learning setting
but i don't think we have those in batch
reinforcement learning um
in my group and one of my collaborators
we've done some work there's very
limited other work
but in general i just don't think we're
there yet and i think it would be great
to have that sort of formal
understanding
um now when i say this what do i want it
to incorporate
i think it has to be able to incorporate
finite samples we have to think about
the fact that data is finite
has to be suitable for the types of
really rich problems we consider so
continuous and vectored state spaces
um we have to think about the fact that
uh different function approximation
classes
um have different expressivity and that
will fundamentally change the sort of
policies that are representable
and ideally and i'll try to come back to
this at the end is to make minimal
assumptions on the underlying stochastic
decision process
i just think in in many cases we just
don't know really how those systems work
um and so we make minimalist minimal
assumptions we're more likely to have
things that will be able to generalize
well
okay so that's sort of you know a
theoretical goal but most people don't
actually do
structural risk minimization and
practice and so another goal
that i think we would like to have is
something like um
cross validation let me just go back so
another thing that we would like to have
is cross validation
um and in this case you know we often
have in the supervised line actually
just one second um my kids are on their
recess period and so let me see if i can
just convince them to be a little bit
quieter one minute
thanks for your patience um so the other
thing that i would really love to
have is cross-validation or the
equivalent which is
we have something practical like we can
partition our data into
a trade and test split um and then we
can have some sort of procedure that we
run
so that empirically we can just do this
and find policies we can reliably deploy
for the future
um i find often when i talk to people
particularly not in reinforcement
learning and they say well
why don't we just do cross validation
like how is the the batch reinforcement
learning problem hard
um i think it's hard for a number of
reasons um one of the reasons is that
even if we have sort of a trained test
split
what should we do with that test set
that data is fundamentally normally from
a different distribution
of states and actions than the data that
we have access to
and so we still need to be able to
tackle this problem of like off policy
batch
evaluation and that's still that's
getting closer to be in a closed area
but i don't think
it's closed yet um second is we probably
want a method that actually provides us
with confidence intervals maybe a lower
bound something like what um
tagging was mentioning and we don't
always have that um
and also we haven't really converged
upon how we should operate on the
training set
so you know how do we do that policy
search on the training set to find
things that we think are likely to do
well on the test set
um i think there's some promising
approaches um my former postdoc phil
thomas who's a professor at umass
amherst
um had some really nice work on safe
policy improvement
but i think that there's still a lot of
open questions there about how to do
this in a data efficient scalable
computationally efficient way
so in terms of making progress towards
this um i think it's helpful to think
about
for me at least to think about sort of
what are the tasks what are the
assumptions and what are the evaluation
criteria we're going to use to try to
consider across these different methods
and in particular i think we want to
often make a number of common
assumptions that i think it's helpful to
be explicit about
we're going to assume the process is
stationary meaning that we're going to
be fundamentally in the same ndp now as
we were in the data that
that we you know when we collected the
data originally this won't be true in
all
real cases but that's almost always
assumed in the methods right now
we commonly assume it's markov we also
assume that there are no
pieces of information that we use to
make the decisions that we don't have
access to now
so if a physician you know sort of
looked whether somebody
seemed a little bit pale or their speech
was kind of blurred
but they didn't actually record that an
electronic medical record system
that could introduce confounding uh i
think that's a really interesting and
important issue
but we're going to ignore that for today
and then finally something that i'm
going to talk a lot about today and can
you also mention and i'm sure sergey
will as well
is overlap which is the idea that
we assume that the behavior data we have
access to covers the states and actions
and that we are interested in visiting
or evaluating under
new potential target policies
and then i think another thing it's
useful to be explicit about is that
often and heard in different ones of our
algorithms we're assuming that either
computational efficiency is really
important
or that performance accuracy is really
important okay
so what or i'm just going to skip a
little bit ahead because i'm
running a little behind right now so i'm
just going to say that you know a lot of
the standard
theoretical work which is where this
work came out of um
has really focused on cases where you
have some strong assumptions
under kind of the process and the type
of approximators we're considering
so we often thought about cases where
you could do a bellman backup and still
stay in the function approximation class
that's called completeness
um we assume that the real q star is
actually realizable in your function
class realizability
and then finally this overlap assumption
which sort of indicates that
for this ada here for any um state
action distribution that is reachable
under a particular policy in your
current mdp
that you have good support essentially
you can sort of uh visit and um
uh get sufficient data under for any
state action distribution that's
reachable
okay and i'll just uh nan and his
students have some recent work that
maybe one of these isn't required
okay so you know a lot of the approaches
historically that are on the
purely focus on the theoretical side
have tried to think about these types of
objectives but often have some
significant limitations due to the
strongness of these assumptions
um and so one of our interests was
is well can we do something more like
kind of guaranteeing you could find a
best-in-class policy
we want to do this in a way that is
inspired by structural risk minimization
so it should think about sort of what is
the policy class
expressivity or the function class
expressivity
and i just want to highlight i know this
is theory of rl so probably almost all
of us are interested in theory of rl but
this is a really important question
for um d viral as well so i think over
the last like two to three years um
there's been a lot of um recognition
that
with finite data and with the types of
methods that are commonly used in dbrl
you can get sort of overfitting due to
maximization with respect to the sort of
uncertainty quantification
so i put up this figure from bcq from a
from a couple years ago where you can
see really that this makes a very big
difference in the types of returns you
get
so if you ignore this sort of
maximization bias that can happen due to
limited um samples and maximizing with
respect to that
that this can matter a lot so it's not
just a sort of theoretical question but
it's something that could inform more
practical approaches
so why you know what is happening here i
think one of the big challenges
is that with finite amounts of data you
might not have overlap so just as a
recall if we imagine we have three
different actions
um and maybe i this is the sort of
policy you want to evaluate
if you had some policy that covers all
of these then um you have sufficient
data or if you have sufficient coverage
particularly enough data
but you know if some actions are never
taken like you never
put really really sick patients on a
ventilator um then
you're just not going to be evaluated
able to evaluate this policy
and this can be subtle because you often
don't have exact access to the behavior
policy
so this is a sort of i think this issue
of this kind of
lack of conservatism has attracted
substantial interest in the last few
years
but i think it's really helpful for me
at least in my group to um think about
small examples which help us
illustrate whether or not different
approaches have strengths or limitations
at least when we think about this in
generalization so in our paper we
propose a couple different really small
tabular examples to try to distinguish
between some of the recent approaches
this is a really simple chain example
for time i'm not going to go through all
of it
but what we found essentially is that
some of the existing approaches um
still can fail in some of these simple
settings um and so what you can see here
is this sort of slightly surprising
behavior
where here's the success rate of finding
the optimal policy
um uh not surprisingly our approach is
in green um
and uh but what you can see here is that
some of these other common recent
approaches
sort of have this interesting behavior
where maybe they do okay at the
beginning and then actually they do
worse with a little bit more data
and then they do better again now why
might this happen
um well this happens in this particular
case because a number of the approaches
only think about mismatch between
actions not between state actions
and if you only think about that then if
you have limited data from some rare
states
and those rare states have an
overestimate of their reward
then your methods can get misled so it's
sort of not capturing this state action
distribution this match
and um and what we can see in this and
we can show also that this can happen
for some other domains even that rely on
the behavior policy sort of for a
related reason that if your behavior
policy itself doesn't have a lot of data
even your estimate of the behavior
policy value
may be misleading so the idea we have is
quite related to
some of the recent sort of concurrent
work um on pessimistic approaches from
model based so i think a number of us
that have all converged on this type of
idea
in our work what we thought about this
for is from over the marginalized state
action distribution so it's a model free
method
and what we're looking at is whether or
not sort of an estimate of the state
action distribution exceeds a threshold
and what you can think of this as is
this sort of threshold can account for
statistical uncertainty due to finite
samples
and we can put this into our development
operators whether evaluation operators
or maximization operators
so essentially we're just restricting
ourselves um to think about parts of the
state action space
where we think we have sufficient
support sufficient data to be able to
accurately estimate um sort of our state
action distribution and values there
and we're going to assume here that the
rewards for the whole domain are bounded
below by zero
which implies that we're essentially
using a pessimistic um
estimate here for those other state
action pairs that sort of indicator
function will be zero if we don't have
enough data and therefore we'll use a
pessimistic estimate
so very similar to mobile and morale
sort of at a high level in terms of
pessimism
we call this marginalized behavior
supported mvi
so i just want to contrast this with
prior work in terms of the theory
prior work said let's assume that in
your data you have sort of this coverage
and support
and given that you could get bounds on
the on the distance to
the true optimal policy what we're
saying is let's define a class
where that class is only policies that
have sufficient support
so now your data is defining your policy
class
and then we're going to do the best we
can with respect to policies in that
class
i just want to be clear here we're not
explicitly constructing this policy
class
just that's what our algorithm is sort
of implicitly doing
quickly two three minutes left for the
talk yeah perfect thank you
um so we i'll i'll leave the assumptions
up here um i think they're important i'm
happy to talk more about them in the
questions or later um these are sort of
what allow us to have some of the nice
theoretical guarantees
um what we get in this case is something
like the following so we get these sort
of bounds that are starting to go
towards this sort of srm type
approach in the sense that what we have
here you probably can't see my mouse but
we think about the size of the function
class that's used to represent the value
function
the size of the policy class um and then
we get balance with respect to that
and that sort of threshold b that we're
using so we can do this both for the
policy iteration setting
and for the value iteration setting and
the nice thing here is that now we're
not having to recover
require coverage everywhere we're just
trying to get coverage within um
the supported class okay and note that
this covers you know function
approximation and finite samples
okay and then how does this work
empirically well i think there are um
and i'm looking forward to
talking about this more there are a lot
of challenges empirically in the sense
that we do have to estimate
the state action distribution which is a
hard problem there's been some really
nice work by
various colleagues on this over the last
few years um but i think in general that
that can be challenging
but we can see here in some domains is
that we can get substantially better
outcomes
and better policies than some of the
prior approaches
so i just want to spend one minute and
say how does this compare to model based
approaches
you know we just heard about mobile from
tenu um
there's morel um and a number of other
ones i think that empirically they're
they're very promising um i think that
that we could
hopefully see some even stronger
theoretical results for those cases
so um last night thanks to yao we have
been looking this weekend to try to see
if we can do some comparison as i
mentioned
all of these works are concurrent so
none of them really compare to each
other
what we can see here is that on some of
the d4rl
recent methods they're somewhat sort of
mixing so you can see that in our um
some of the
times we do better than some of these
other approaches other times they're
sort of all kind of the same
other times i think sometimes some of
these other methods do better
personally i suspect that the model
based approaches are often going to do
better on the d4-rrl cases
or places where you might be off to have
a pretty good inductive bias for the
model
whether theoretically they're always
better and whether it really depends on
how
the algorithm is used i think it's a
really interesting open question
um so i think there's excited to learn
more from my colleagues about this
so just to summarize you know this is um
uh thinking about how do we try to do
the best with
the data that we have it's sort of a
simple idea of using pessimism but with
respect to the marginalized state action
distribution
and our theoretical results are i'm
pretty strong in terms of being able to
think about
um how well do we do compared to the
best supported policy
and i just want to highlight in terms of
making progress towards this
cross-validation for rl
i think that these type of pessimism
approaches um including some of the nice
recent work by
mark and his colleagues uh are really
promising um they sort of account
explicitly for uncertainty due to finite
data
i do think there's a lot of room to be
he's a really exciting area for future
work um in part because i think that a
lot of the existing approaches still
rely strongly on
the markov assumption and some correct
model specification
that i think is too strong for sort of
high stakes domains
and so i think this will be a really
exciting area to think about in the
future
thanks thank you hermetis is fantastic
um i have lots of questions to ask but
just a sense and the timekeeper also say
uh we it's okay to run over the
what's what's one o'clock for me so i
have to do math now i believe it's 10
a.m for you
maybe we'll start sergey stock at uh
1002 1003
we can eat into the coffee break just a
little bit so without further ado
i think uh gerger you have a question
for emma let's start there
uh yeah that's right thank you emma so i
was
i was just wondering about
your approach again so i was just
wondering what happens
if you have mu s a smaller than b
for every action in a state so
do you just default to some fixed policy
in that case or or what happens then
maybe i didn't get this right
like how do you use this meal
thanks for the question and so what
would happen there is that when you're
doing sort of policy evaluation or
you're doing bellman backups
um that would have a zero value and so
you would hopefully get a policy that
doesn't reach states
that have no support and so that would
be one of the things that would happen
automatically
we also consider um uh some forms of
safe policy improvement which says well
if at least you cover your behavior
policy
in each state then there will always be
at least one action that is well
supported
right yeah all right yeah thank you that
makes sense
i i just want to highlight one anonymous
question which was whether policy
iteration has worse
sample complexity compared to value
iteration um sorry if that was unclear
actually the results that we have are
stronger for the policy iteration case
compared to value iteration
value iteration actually has an
additional term um kind of a pesky term
that we don't like
so i think that our results are actually
stronger in the policy iteration case
whether that means empirically um i
think there's a big gap between sort of
the
theoretical results and empirical
results so which ones actually work
better empirically it is still open
okay do we have more questions from the
panel panelists
it's doubly difficult because i have to
wait for for the microphone icon icon to
uh to come up if not maybe i'll ask the
next q next question
um i'm curious as you pointed that
emma it seems like uh a lot of people uh
in fact many of them on this call
uh came to the same conclusion at the
same time which is exciting it means we
must be looking at the right solution
concept
um how does the filtration function
differ is it equivalent to having a
penalty on the reward or is it
fundamentally different
mechanistically um i think that's a
great question i personally think it's
basically equivalent at a high level i
think both so i didn't show results
for mopo or morel on our sort of
negative examples um
those small little mdps um our guess is
that they will work exactly the same as
art does and in fact we haven't looked
into this i think we described my guess
is that there would be an exact
equivalence
between um a threshold on the
marginalized state action in terms of
that b
and sort of an equivalent penalized
reward so my guess is that you could
probably make a one-to-one mapping at
least in the tabular case
function approximation and practical
algorithms always get a little more
complicated but
um i think that sort of from a high
level they're doing exactly the same
thing they're both considering the state
action space and they're both saying
if you don't have sufficient data there
um
because of limited you know samples then
we should penalize
that or like in the case of morale it's
sort of a strict function
cut off just like our max
okay maybe if uh i will ask another
question then
um and this is actually something that
came up uh i think
tenure's talking fantastic correctly was
for the continuous state space case
um
it seems like an important open question
in continuous spaces if we have
technically you could say you have
coverage everywhere if you're willing to
generalize your sample
to the rest of the you know and i'm
guessing
in a health application for example
that's going to be something you
necessarily need to do
you're no longer in a tabular setting uh
have you thought about this a little bit
is continuous a way to deal with this
data coverage problem
or is it just a delegating it to a
different
you know shifting the the burden
somewhere else
but i think uh both china i think all of
the recent works that i know of
uh like mobile mural and us all of us
continue can um
do at least empirically have um
continuous state space results
um i don't think it solves it i think
that
one might end up sort of pushing a lot
of model miss specification
into that part of the into part of the
problem and i think you could always
have a really simple model and then you
have sufficient data coverage but then
your model misspecification will be
enormous
the the results that i'm that i showed
you know in the slides here
don't cover that neither do the results
from the other recent work
and i think that's a really interesting
and hard question and in fact i've been
looking at um
some recent colleagues and i'm excited
for friday on calibration and i think
that if we can understand better
and quantify the bias of these models
then we can incorporate that because i
think that
empirically often even if there is some
bias they're often much much better than
sort of more important sampling or less
restrictive assumptions
but we often just don't know how far off
they are and so maybe we could use some
form of calibration methods to try to
quantify it
okay uh perfect well thank you emma
maybe sergey can
you can set up while we take one last
question for
emma uh and that's our case
okay uh well if there are no more
questions thank you again emma and i
think we will continue the discussion at
11 30.